October has managed to creep around the
corner once again so what better time to
look at some more cryptids than the
month of horror today we travel to
Philadelphia to take a look at one of
its most famous pieces of folklore only
second to the trashman the Jersey Devil
as its name tells us the Jersey Devil
was said to inhabit southern Jersey in
the Pine Barrens a heavily forested area
just off the coast most cryptids are
fairly easy to describe because they
resemble some kind of animal the Jersey
Devil does also kind of fall into this
category but it's far from easy to paint
you a picture without actually showing
you one over the years has been
described as a number of different
things but the most consistent is as a
flying by peed with hooves which
honestly means nothing when its
appearance varies so much bat-like wings
and hooves are the features that never
really change its head is either said to
be a goat or a horse with horns
it has small clawed arms and a forked
tail
many have liken the creature to a wyvern
and I guess it is a reasonable
comparison it does kind of remind me of
a chimera but with the only one head
so other than flying around in the
scaring people what does the Jersey
Devil actually do naturally with it
being the devil it was seen as a bad
omen everything from a bad harvest to
droughts missing livestock and even cows
who couldn't be milked were all blamed
on the Jersey Devil
then you have other sinister activities
such as knocking down trees to squash
people and boil in streams of water to
burn them alive some believe that it
appeared periodically either every 7 or
13 years a sign of war disaster and
hardship that was yet to come with the
overall description out of the way the
next few questions we can attempt to
answer are what is it and where did it
come from for this we have to go back to
the 18th century when it was first seen
in 1735 in the Pine Barrens region lived
a woman named Jane Leeds also known as
mother Leeds
despite being very poor Jane had no less
than 12 children with a 13th on the way
when Jane found out she was pregnant
once again she cursed the child in her
frustration claiming that this child
would be the devil when the night came
that Jane went into labor there was a
terrible storm that shook the entire
house as her friends and family gathered
to help her through the pregnancy the
child was born normal
but it began to change into a deformed
monstrosity its feet turned into hooves
its head resembled a goat leathery wings
sprouted from its back and a forked tail
whipped of violently around the room the
child screamed and thrashed its tail
would anyone trying to hold it down
eventually it broke free and flew up
into the chimney escaping into the pines
the local clergyman believed in it was a
demon tried an exorcism to remove it
from the area but they were unsuccessful
there are versions of this tale where
the local salt mother Leeds was a witch
or a sorceress of some kind and the
reason the child was and what a demon
was because the father was the devil
this is also why at first the creature
was known as the Leeds devil or the
devil of Leeds a mixture of the family
name and the town they lived in known as
Leeds point the credibility of this
story or even the possibility that it
might be rooted in any real history is
questionable at best there was a woman
named Jane Leeds who was married to a
Daniel Leeds but there doesn't seem to
be any connection between them and a
devil child
despite this the newspapers of the 18th
century still printed the story numerous
times over the years was it an
interesting story that would help them
sell copies yeah I'm sure it was was it
a story that would lead people to visit
the area again I'm sure it did and still
does the point that I'm trying to make
is regardless of how true this story may
have been printing it had numerous
benefits so it's difficult to take that
as undeniable evidence another
explanation is that mother Leeds was
actually a woman named Deborah Leeds who
was married to a japhet Leeds they both
are lived in Leeds Point and in 1730
gephart named twelve children as part of
his will which does line up with the
original legend but was that a
coincidence maybe the women in Leeds
Point were just baby factories or maybe
japhet was the father of the Jersey
Devil
either way leaving your devil child out
of the inheritance sounds like it can
only end poorly another possible origin
story is about a girl from Leeds Point
who fell in love of a British soldier
during the American Revolution in 1778
the Battle of chestnut neck took place
in southern New Jersey so there would
have been more than a slight bit of
disdain between the two sides the girl
then meeting with this soldier in secret
and eventually fallen pregnant with his
child meant that this was seen as
treason and so that hound cursed the
girl and her child this resulted in her
then given birth to a child that would
later become the Leeds or Jersey Devil
there are no credible photos of the
Jersey Devil so all we have to go by are
the accounts of people who have claimed
to have seen the creature and there have
been quite a few over the years one of
the most famous sightings comes from
Joseph Bonaparte the elder brother of
Napoleon
Joseph swore that he saw a devilish
creature fly by when hunting game on the
grounds of his born in town estate in
1820 a few decades later in 1840 the
locals claimed to have seen the creature
again in the same place this time
killing livestock a year later in 1841
similar sightings were reported once
again this time claiming they heard
screams and saw tracks in the snow
in 1925 sightings around livestock
continued when a farmer claimed that he
saw an animal that he could not identify
trying to steal his chickens he fetched
his rifle and fired hitting his target
and killing the animal he took photos of
its corpse and showed it to over a
hundred people but none of them could
identify what it wants it does raise the
question of how one would kill such a
creature
clearly the farmer believed his rifle
did the job but there are some stories
that slightly contradict this when
Commodore Stephen DeSoto visited the
Hannover mill
to inspect cannonballs that will be made
for his ship he was in for quite a
surprise he said that he saw an enormous
creature flying above him in a menacing
fashion the Commodore then fired a
cannonball at the creature but to his
surprise it did nothing as the creature
flew by unharmed
the amount of alleged encounters and
sightings from regular townsfolk is
quite interesting because of how wildly
they can differ there's a story that
comes from a sheriff and some of his
officers that makes it seem as if the
Jersey Devil is more than just a
mindless monster the sheriff and his men
were chasing the Jersey Devil away from
a farm where the owner had reported
missing cattle and blood-curdling
screams the devil then fled into the
woods leaving the men at the edge too
scared to chase any further the sheriff
then yelled if it is true and you are
the devil then rattle your chains all of
the men swore that they heard its chains
rattle this story ties into the previous
versions that believe the father of the
child may have been the devil it's also
a rare account of the creature
attempting to interact in some way that
doesn't involve a sinister act the Leeds
devil was a story that started in the
18th century and for the next few
centuries stories about a creature that
stalks the Pine Barrens spread to the
surrounding areas by the 19th century
has become part of New Jersey's folklore
and tradition a ghost story that you
would tell your friends and family on a
dark and stormy night it wasn't until
the 20th century that people started to
refer to it as the Jersey Devil this is
also when it was given its general
appearance what had previously been
referred to as an animal a demon or a
monster was now a weird mix between a
goat and a kangaroo 1909 was the year
the Jersey Devil went from a piece of
folklore known in New Jersey to a legend
that almost everyone in North America
had heard of January 16th until January
23rd marked the most significant week in
the Jersey Devils history newspapers
published hundreds of claimed encounters
and sightings all over the state up
until then sightings have been quite
sporadic and mostly occurred in the same
area these encounters ranged from
attacks in a Camden social club to the
police shoot in the creature in Bristol
Pennsylvania they even went as far as
Delaware and Maryland created a snowball
effect the more people heard of the
Jersey Devil the more people reported
seeing it it almost created a mass panic
to the point where schools and local
businesses were closed warning people to
stay indoors where it was safe groups of
hunters vigilantes and concerned
individuals traveled to New Jersey in
search of the creature wealthy
collectors even offered rewards up to
$10,000 for the creatures capture some
didn't care if it was dead wanting it
for their own private collection whereas
others were willing to donate the
creature to the Philadelphia Zoo as we
can imagine with that amount of money
being thrown around at that time the
hoaxes began as people trying to make
some quick cash in all the hysteria all
sorts of animals were handed in with the
claim that they had found the creature
someone even attached wings and claws to
the corpse of a kangaroo in the hopes
that those desperate enough would pay
after that week of madness the Jersey
Devil had cemented itself as an American
urban legend
the number of reported sightings did
eventually die down as people went about
their lives as usual several
explanations were offered as to what the
Jersey Devil was and why it came to be
the simplest being that hundreds of
years ago it was very common to
misidentify animals and what people may
have seen may have just been a hill
crane though it is quite hard to match
that description to the Jersey Devil
there's also the possibility that
British settlers may have just created a
boogeyman story a form of entertainment
or even a way to keep their children
safe the Pine Barrens were a dangerous
harsh and unwelcoming place to live
it was also rampant with bandits and
highwayman who would rob and kill those
passing by so making up a story about an
evil creature to scare people away from
the Pine Barrens seemed like a smart way
to keep them as safe although this plan
doesn't really work when your story
actually encourages more people to visit
the area personally I've always been a
fan of folklore and legends that are
unique to specific areas there are so
many Universal ideas throughout folklore
it's always refreshing when you get
something as weird as this story let me
know what you think I'm sure some of you
watching this currently live in New
Jersey I'd love to hear if you have any
stories growing up or if you know
someone who claims they have seen the
Jersey Devil as always I've been your
host mythology and fiction explained
reminding you to maybe stop at 12
children because the 13th might just be
the devil